The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TADGE DRYJA: Today,
I'm going to talk
about signatures and all
sorts of different signature
kind of things.
In the problem set, you're
working with signatures,
but you're working with
hash-based signatures, which
are not actually used
in bitcoin at all.
But we'll talk about those.
OK.
So if you've gotten
through the homework,
there's lamport
signatures, right?
These are hash-based signatures.
And they use hash functions.
So it's fairly straightforward.
You can understand them.
There's nothing
super crazy going on.
The code is fairly compact.
So that's cool.
What are some disadvantages
of these lamport signatures?
Does anyone-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: You can
only use it once.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
OK.
So plus.
This is hashes.
That's cool.
One-time use.
Other possible disadvantages of
them relative to other systems,
if you're aware.
Another is they're kind of
huge, kind of big, right?
You can deal with it.
But if you were
looking in the forge,
or that file with
the signatures,
it's like, what, 8K
for a signature--
8 kilobytes-- kind of big.
Keys are 16 kilobytes--
kind of annoying.
Private keys are
also 16 kilobytes.
So yes, sig 8K,
16K priv/pub key.
So that's some disadvantages.
So since I don't
have slides, I'm
gonna make this more
fun and interactive.
What are some solutions
for these problems?
So we can actually
mitigate/solve
both of these things to
a pretty good extent.
So how about the first
one, one-time use?
What would be a
fairly obvious way
to mitigate the
one-time use problem?
And don't think the
answer is too stupid.
It may be a fairly stupid
answer, and it might work.
So yeah?
AUDIENCE: Not actually revealing
pieces of your private key?
Instead, reveal something else.
TADGE DRYJA: There's
probably some clever way.
But that might be too clever.
Something really simple for,
OK, I can only use a key once.
How can I use a "key," quote
unquote, more than once?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Make another one.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
You can make another key.
So you could say, well, I've
got this 16 kilobyte public key.
Well, I'm going to make
a 32 kilobyte public key.
And it's just two public
keys stuck together.
And now, when I
make a signature,
I just put an extra
bit in the front.
And I say, well, this
signature is using key 0
or this signature
is using key 1,
and it's got the
whole signature after.
And then you look through
this 32 kilobyte public key,
and you say, OK, well,
it starts with a zero,
so that means it's using the
first key, the first subkey
in this 32 byte
public key block.
And in this case,
it's using one,
so that means it's
using the latter subkey.
So that would work.
That would let you use
your public key twice,
at the cost of doubling
your public key size, which
is not really great, right?
And it's not very efficient.
But it does sort of work.
OK.
Any clever ways to do
it more efficiently?
Or wait.
So OK, also, I'll give
you sort of a hint.
In this case, let's say this is
pub sub 0 and pub sub 1, right?
And then, your 32 byte
pubkey is just them
concatenated together, right--
pub0, pub1.
What would happen to the private
keys in this case, right?
How would private
keys work here?
Same expansion of size, I guess.
Can anyone think of a way to
mitigate the expansion of size
of private keys in this case?
So the private keys are
the preimages here, right?
They lead into these
public key blocks.
So you could just
say, OK, well, I
have twice the size private
key leading into twice the size
public key.
Could you do that
more efficiently?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could you just
hash the private key
so that you have two
hashes instead of one?
TADGE DRYJA: Yes.
So let's say you
have this 16k block,
and you want this to
turn into two public key.
So that's the basic
good way to do it.
And it sort of
turns in like that.
How exactly-- what's
the way you do that?
AUDIENCE: You can keep the
same private key as before
and just add something like
zero or one to indicate--
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
So this is a hash
function, right?
And so before, we just said,
OK, hash of this is block 0,
this is block 1,
this is block 2.
So the idea of pub--
let's see.
Is this visible?
This might be too small, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
TADGE DRYJA: Yes, OK.
Let me make this bigger.
Sorry.
OK.
So in these diagrams, you've
got your private key right now.
And it's in these big blocks.
And there's 256 of them,
but let's keep it small.
And the idea is these are 32
byte blocks with random numbers
in it.
And then you hash it
to get your public key.
So we say, OK, pub2--
and this is public, this
is private, and, let's say,
secret--
pub2 is just the hash
of secret2, right?
But yeah.
What we could do is we could
sort of have two different hash
functions.
And then a real
simple way to make
a whole bunch of
different hash functions
is we define, OK,
well hash0 is defined
as the hash function of whatever
your input x is concatenated
with the number 0.
And then hash1, we define
as just x comma 1 and so on.
And this is actually secure.
You could do this.
Any questions or
possible objections?
AUDIENCE: I was thinking that if
someone knew the hash function
you're using, wouldn't
they only define
x because they know that it
won't help with [INAUDIBLE] x.
[INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: Yes.
Yes.
So there's no real entropy
or secrets in this 0 and 1.
But it's purely
riding on x, right?
But the idea is,
well, if I do this,
and I say, OK, well
pub2 is the hash
of secret2 concatenated with
0, yeah, if you know secret2,
you can go back.
Because 0 is obvious.
But the idea is if you don't
know secret2, the fact that you
know the last byte of the hash
input doesn't really help you.
Because there's all this
data that you don't know.
And so you're not going to
be able to find a preimage.
You're like, OK, I
know the preimage
to public2 ends with a 0 byte.
What are the other 32 bytes
that come before that?
You still can't go back
to make a preimage.
AUDIENCE: But it feels
like there's some sort of--
what's the word-- you'd make a
similar statement saying, oh,
if the last byte
is not important,
then the second-to-last byte is
not important, either, right?
TADGE DRYJA: So the
attack is I've got pub2,
which is a 32 byte hash output.
I want to find
what this thing is.
Now, I do know what the
last byte is, right?
It's going to be,
let's say, 33 bytes,
and the last byte is a 0.
And this is going to
be some random numbers
all the way back.
So I have some insight
into what the preimage is.
I know the last byte is a 0.
But that doesn't
help because I don't
know all the bytes before that.
So I can't really do--
I can't sign because I
need to be able to reveal
all these things.
And the way the hash
functions, if it's a good hash
function, the fact that you
know some part of the preimage
shouldn't give you insight
into the other parts
of the preimage.
Because it looks really random.
And adding stuff to the end
here shouldn't reveal anything.
There are hash functions
where this can be dangerous,
and you can consider those like
broken hash functions, where
if I concatenate a lot
of known data at the end,
it might give me properties of
the public key that I can find.
[INAUDIBLE],, as far as
we know, it works fine.
Most of the hash functions
work fine this way.
So yeah, you can do this.
And then you can
say, OK, well, I'm
going to use hash function
0 to make pubkey 0, right?
This is pubkey 0.
And if I use hash function
1, I make pubkey 1.
Now I have a 16 kilobyte--
let me erase this--
so now what I can do
is I can say, OK, well,
I have a 16 kilobyte
secret key, private key,
but I have a 32
kilobyte public key
that I can use twice
that has two subkeys
so I don't have to store as
much of my private key data.
So that's cool.
That makes it quite
a bit more efficient.
Does anyone have an idea of how
to get it even more efficient
for private key storage?
You can actually get
it very efficient
using this kind of idea.
Any ideas?
Yeah.
Well, you--
So some hints.
This is pretty useful, right?
The idea is, well,
even if you know
what the sort of suffix
of all these things
are, if you don't
know x, you're not
going to be able to find
the preimage, right?
So maybe add some
more stuff here.
Any idea?
Oh, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could
you hash the index?
TADGE DRYJA: Right.
Right.
So instead of just
saying 0 and 1,
we can say here, well, why
not just have one chunk?
And there's one chunk, and
it's got random number x.
Well, this is hash x comma 0.
This is hash x comma 1.
This is hash x comma 2.
OK.
So yeah.
So what you can do is you can--
this was before, right,
where I said, OK, yeah,
but this is basically how to
do a 32 byte private key where
your private key is
actually quite small,
and you just derive
all of the public keys
by adding numbers at the
end, concatenating them
into your hash.
And now you're like, OK, cool.
I have a 32 byte
private key, and I
can make enormous
public keys from them,
and it's still secure, right?
Because I can add whatever
number I want here.
And I can do this
a million times,
and no one will be able to find
the preimage, even though I'm
giving you all these
related hashes, right?
It's x comma 0, x comma
1, x comma a million.
I can give you millions of them.
And each time I do it,
it doesn't give you
any insight into how
to find what x is--
if it's a good hash function.
So that's really powerful.
And now I can say, OK, the
private key problem is solved.
I have 0 of 1 growth
in my private key.
I can make as many public
keys as I want, never
gets any bigger.
Cool.
Still have this problem with
the public keys, though.
Let's say I want
to sign four times.
OK.
Well, I make a 64
kilobyte pubkey.
Now I can sign four times.
Great.
But my public key size expands
with the number of signatures
I ever want to do.
Any ideas on how you
could mitigate that
or how you could still
make a usable system,
despite this fact?
There's a couple
different techniques.
Any ideas?
OK.
So one would be
every time I sign,
I also sign my next pubkey.
You can do that.
It's got some downsides, right?
So the idea is I first publish
one 16 kilobyte pubkey.
And then I say, OK, when I sign,
I'm going to sign my message.
And concatenated to that
message will be my next pubkey.
And so I'm signing something
and also indicating
what my next public key
will be that I sign with.
Then I can still maintain
a small private key
and then keep signing.
The problem is, in order
for someone to verify,
they're going to need to look at
all of my previous signatures,
right?
So if I'm saying, hey,
here's my 500th public key
that I'm signing with,
here's the message,
you're going to have to go back
and look at my entire history
of signing, which is not great.
OK.
So other ideas of how to
deal with large pubkeys?
What's a way you could do this?
So hints.
Is there any kind
of data function
we've seen here where it takes
an arbitrary sized amount
of data and outputs
a fixed size?
[LAUGHING]
In fact, it's the
only thing we've
been talking about so far.
So what would you do to make
your public keys smaller?
AUDIENCE: Hash.
TADGE DRYJA: Hash them.
Right.
OK.
So you say, well,
yeah, 32 byte pubkey.
Well, you just
commit to the pubkey
with the hash of the
whole thing, right?
And I say, well, I've got
my 16 kilobyte by pubkey.
I just hash it, right?
And now I have a
32 byte public key.
And I've committed.
That works, right?
I've committed to my public key.
However, when I sign, I need
to provide the whole public key
in order for you to verify.
I need to provide this
whole 16 original pubkey,
original version pubkey,
after when I sign.
So now my signature goes
from 8K to, what, 24K.
So I haven't really made
it more efficient, right,
in that the total thing with
public keys and signatures
stays the same size--
actually, slightly larger.
But this is kind of a game.
Because the public
key, it might be
like I'm showing it
to you beforehand,
and we're
space-constrained there.
And then, when I'm
doing the signature,
I have more space or time
or something like that.
So this is actually useful.
And actually, this
technique is used
in Bitcoin and all
different cryptocurrencies,
where you can call
this a pubkey hash--
pubkey hash, or they say PKH.
And the main benefit
is size, right?
You could say, well, if I've
got a really big pubkey,
I can commit to it by sending
to the hash of the pubkey.
And then, when I
later want to sign,
I reveal the actual pubkey.
You can do it that way.
OK.
So then this is
pretty cool, right?
We've now taken our system,
which had fairly large--
16 kilobyte-- private
keys, turned them
into 32 byte private keys.
Great.
And also, this is 0
of 1-- never expands.
Awesome.
We've taken a system with
large, potentially huge--
32 kilobyte, 64
kilobyte-- public keys.
We've got it down to 32 bytes.
Awesome.
OK.
We've now made this thing
much more efficient, much more
useful.
The problem-- the
signatures are still big.
They actually got
a little bit bigger
because they include the full
public key in the signature.
And let's say we had
one of these things,
where we make a
bunch of public keys
and commit to them
at the outset.
So you say, OK, I've got
a 64 kilobyte pubkey.
I can commit to the whole
thing by hashing it.
However, then, when I reveal and
want to give you a signature,
my signature is now
whatever it'll be--
72, right?
The signature would
be 72 kilobytes--
kind of huge.
So I can add a bunch
of keys, but I'm just
sort of pushing the
problem somewhere else--
into the signature, right?
There's a better way to
commit to many public keys.
It's maybe not super obvious
unless you've seen it before.
But if you have,
do you know what
the better way to commit
to many public keys is?
Or you could come up
with it on the spot,
and it'd be like, wow,
you should have gotten
this stuff named after you.
Any idea?
OK.
So what you can do--
it's a little non-obvious--
you can make a tree, right?
So the idea is instead
of just saying,
oh, I'm going to take all
four of my big pubkeys,
stick them all in a row, take
the hash of that whole thing
and publish that
as my public hash,
I'm going to have a little
bit more complex design.
And that design
is a binary tree.
OK.
So the idea is here are my four
public keys that take up 64K
each.
I can make these
intermediate hashes.
So I make a binary tree
where I say, OK, this
is the hash of the first
two keys stuck together.
This is the hash of the second
The top is the hash of these
two intermediate hashes
stuck together.
And then, this top
is my root, which is
equivalent to my pubkey hash.
And so I can publish this,
and it commits me to all four
of my public keys.
So it might not be obvious.
Do you see any
advantages that this
could have over just
concatenating all four
of the keys and hashing it?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm confused.
Where is your
private key in this?
TADGE DRYJA: The private
key is down here, right?
The private key is not shown.
But I have a private key.
It turns into these pubkeys.
And we can use the
technique here,
where we just have, really,
one 32 byte private key
and create all the different
chunks of all the public keys
by concatenating
different indices.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You can do [INAUDIBLE]
systems and log-in time instead
of linear time.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, exactly.
I can prove that, hey,
this is public key 0, which
is in here, this root hash, and
I don't have to reveal all four
in order to do it.
So yeah.
Did someone else have,
probably, the same idea?
Yeah, OK.
OK.
So how are we going to do that?
You obviously know.
Anyone else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So assuming you
wanted the public key 0,
you would publish that and
1, and also hash of 2, 3.
TADGE DRYJA: Right, yeah.
And then you can
prove up to the top.
So I have little colors.
So the idea is the verifier
who's verifying the signature,
he already knows
the root, right?
Because you've pre-published
that as your public key,
as your public key root
and your public key hash.
And then that
verifier is provided
with public key 0 saying,
hey, here's a signature.
Here's the message.
Here is public key 0.
So you've got both
of these things.
Now, the prover needs to
prove that public key 0 is
contained within the root.
And to do that, the only two
things the prover needs to add
is pub1--
OK, so the prover says,
here's public key 1.
That allows the verifier
to compute this.
And then the prover
says, hey, here's
hash 2, 3, which allows the
verifier to compute the root
and then check that it's equal.
So yeah, you only need two extra
hashes instead of all four.
So saves some space.
It doesn't save that much
space when you only have four.
It saves a lot of space
when you have 1,000, right?
So you can add 0 of n elements.
And the root stays
the same size.
The root stays 32
bytes, regardless
of how many leaf nodes you have.
And you can prove an
element with log n--
oh, those parentheses
are wrong--
0 log n intermediate hashes.
So if you have 1,000 keys,
your root stays 32 bytes,
and your proofs are going to
be not too, too big, right--
320 bytes of overhead,
which is a bunch smaller
than a signature, right?
So this is really cool.
And you can use this
much more practically
than the raw lamport
signatures that
were in the first problem set.
Because those, if
you're just doing
one key and one signature,
it's about the same size.
But this actually lets
you use it multiple times,
lets you store a much
smaller private key,
commit to much
smaller public keys.
It's a more usable system.
The signatures, though, still
are kind of huge, right?
Your signatures are going
to be a little over 8
kilobytes, which is OK, right?
Computers can deal
with 8 kilobytes.
That's called a Merkle
tree made by Ralph Merkle
in '76 or something.
And it was originally made
for exactly that purpose.
Anyway, so these are
called Merkle trees.
Ralph Merkle.
He doesn't really
work on crypto now.
He works on biotech
stuff now, I think.
Anyway.
But he's cool.
And he gets, like,
everything named after him.
So you will see the
word Merkle everywhere.
And it's, you know, he
invented something cool.
Awesome.
This is one of the
kind of things,
though, where it
seems like, yeah,
I might have been able
to think of that, right?
It's sort of a binary
tree and hash functions.
It's nothing that crazy.
But so there's all
sorts of Merkle trees.
You can make a different thing.
It's used in Bitcoin.
It's used in a bunch of
different cryptocurrencies.
Oh, cool.
It's a very powerful way
to take a whole bunch
of different things and commit
to them in one small thing.
OK.
So this is very cool.
But we can do better.
And so the next things are
things that I definitely
would never have thought
of because it's much more
complex than just, like,
hey, let's use a binary tree
with hashes.
And I will mention
RSA and then go
into ECDSA and elliptic curve
[INAUDIBLE] signatures, which
do different things and are not
based on just hash functions.
So I'll talk about
RSA for a few minutes,
and then we'll have a little
break, like intermission.
And then we'll go into
elliptic curve stuff.
OK.
So RSA was invented by locals.
The R is Ron--
no, I think the R
stands for Rivest,
but Ron Rivest is at
CSAIL, and he's still
working on cool crypto stuff.
It's not used in Bitcoin
or any currency, actually--
well, any currently
operating cryptocurrency.
Because the signatures
and keys are
a bit larger than the
later systems we'll see--
smaller than the hash-based
things, but still a bit larger.
Was used in chaumian
blinded cash.
Because you can do blinded
signatures, where you say,
OK, I'm going to have you
sign something for me,
and then after you
give me the signature,
I can pull apart the signature.
Because I'll have
you sign something
that you don't know what
you're signing, right?
I'm going to mask this
message and blind it
so that you sign the
message, and then I
can get your signature
on the real message
without you knowing
what you signed.
So basically, the idea
is, well, I actually
have message prime equals
message plus randomness.
And I say, hey, can
you sign m prime?
And you say, OK.
I produce a signature on m
prime with my private key.
And we'll call that s prime.
And then what I can do
is I can s equals s prime
minus the randomness,
or, really, some function
of that randomness.
And now I have a signature.
And this is a valid
signature on m.
So that's kind of cool.
It's like, hey, can you
sign this message for me?
And we're not going to tell
you what you're signing.
It seems sort of
useless, like why would I
sign something I have no
idea what I'm signing?
But it can be used in that
chaumian blinded cash.
Because I then have a proof
that, well, this bank didn't
know what they were signing,
but they signed this,
and this is their signature,
and they gave it to me.
And I can use that as a
thing to represent money.
There's all sorts of cool
things you can do with this.
The basic setup of RSA is make
two prime numbers, p and q.
And then compute n, which
is the product p times q.
So this seems fairly
straightforward, right?
It's not too hard.
Everyone knows what
prime numbers are.
Now you have this composite
number, p times q.
How do I make a leading
question for the next slide?
Does this have any relation to
things that we've looked at?
This doesn't look at all
like a hash function, right?
But are there any properties
similar to a hash function
here?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's hard
to route the image.
It's hard to [INAUDIBLE].
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
It's a one-way function
in that if I know p and q,
I can compute n, right?
But given n, I can't
necessarily find p and q, right?
If they're small,
sure, I just check.
And there's all sorts of
algorithms to find factors.
But if p and q are pretty big,
like hundreds of bits long
or thousands of
bits long, finding n
may be impractical, whereas
if p and q are really long,
finding the product of both of
them will be very practical.
Even if huge, multiplying
two integers is really easy.
So this is a one-way function
but not a hash function.
And so a lot of these signature
systems use one-way functions,
but trickier one-way functions
that aren't hash functions,
and still have cool
things that you can do.
So I'm not going to go
into RSA in super detail.
I'm going to run
through it really quick,
and you'll be like,
huh, how does that work?
But if you think it's
interesting, you can look it up
and then maybe you go
to CSAIL and ask Ron
how it works, although maybe
try to look it up first.
He's probably explained
it a lot of times.
But it has different properties.
So you could say, I'm
going to use this p times
q equals n as a hash function
and make a lamport signature
out of it where my private key
is a whole bunch of p and q
pairs, and my public key is
a whole bunch of n's, and I
reveal them and stuff.
You could do that.
That would work.
But you can do much
more powerful things
because of the mathematical
properties of these things.
So yeah, I'm just going to
go through it really fast.
But if you know anything,
this is kind of cool.
The idea is you can do a
bunch of multiplication
and exponential modulo n.
And so because n
is almost prime,
there's some
interesting properties,
where if you know
the factors of n,
you have these
shortcuts you can do.
And someone who doesn't
know the factors of n
can't do these shortcuts.
So you publish e, which is
a constant-- this is sort
of a parameter system.
So RSA is used today
all over the place.
If your computer
is open and you've
been using the web in
the last five seconds,
your computer has
performed RSA calculations.
Every time you connect to a
website, you're doing RSA.
So generally, it's 65537.
They just make this up.
You could also use
three-- some small number.
And then d is a number
that you can compute
if you know what p and q are.
So this is sort of the
private key, right?
p and q itself can be
seen as the private key.
But you can actually
compute this d number
and then discard p and q.
And so this is how you
compute d or whatever.
But the idea is n is your public
key, and d is your private key.
e is always the same, and p and
q, you can discard afterwards.
And then what you can do--
and not going to get into
it-- but you can say, OK,
my signature s is
message, right--
I can take the hash
and make a message m--
message to the d power modulo n.
And if I verify, if I take that
signature to the e power modulo
n, it should equal
m again, which
is crazy and kind of awesome.
Because the idea
is to sign, OK, I
just raised to
the d power mod n.
It's going to be some number
on the same size as n, right?
And then I give that to someone.
They take that signature
to the 65537 power modulo
m again and see if m--
the message-- comes back out.
And if it does,
they know I signed,
and I have the private
key that corresponds to n.
Now, the cool thing is I can
use this any number of times.
I can use the same
thing a bazillion times
with different m's, and
that doesn't give any help
on how to factor n
or how to compute d.
So this was late 70s, also,
RSA, and one of the first,
hey, we can do better
than hash functions.
It was developed at
around the same time
as hash-based signatures.
All of these things were sort
of coming out at the same time.
You can do lots of cool
stuff because there's
these properties where we
can make m prime plus m
and take the exponentiation of
all that, and it still works.
OK.
So that's really cool.
You can do lots of cool stuff.
But this is also
not used in Bitcoin.
One of the things is the size.
So key sizes are smaller
than with lamport signatures.
And they're often about
2 kilobits, or 256 bytes,
which is fine.
And that's the same
size as signatures.
So if you use your web browser--
secure-- well, how secure?
Certificate, valid.
Oh, this browser
might not show me.
OK, never mind.
AUDIENCE: In
Firefox, it'll do it.
TADGE DRYJA: In Firefox,
it tells you more.
OK.
Well, anyway, anyway, anyway.
But yeah, there's RSA keys in,
basically, every certificate
for web browsers and websites.
And they're generally
2,048 bits long.
That's seen as pretty secure.
Even 1,024 bits has
not been hacked.
But people think
it probably could
be by a very motivated actor.
So this is decent size.
One thing about RSA is that it's
a little tricky to implement,
right?
There's a whole bunch
of weird math there.
It's not like the
lamport signatures,
where it's like, OK, I have a
hash function, use it, right?
It's kind of hard
to shoot yourself
in the foot with the
lamport signature scheme.
You can, right, but
it's sort of obvious
if you do, so if you're
doing the homework
and it just doesn't work
at all, and you're like,
oh, I was hashing twice, or,
oh, I was reversing the order,
or it just didn't work.
But there's no subtle ways
where, oh, I was off by one,
and now it reveals
all my private keys.
That's hard to do, whereas in
RSA, it's actually quite easy.
If your p and q
values, for example--
what's a really crazy gotcha--
if p or q minus 1-- so if
p minus 1 or q minus 1--
is smooth-- essentially, a
number that's highly composite
has many small factors--
you can find
someone's private key.
You can factor it.
So it's not just that p
and q have to be prime.
P minus 1 and q minus 1
have to be not too unprime.
It can't be a power
of two or something.
Otherwise, you can
lose your privacy.
So there's all sorts of crazy
things that happen with RSA.
Bitcoin and other coins use
elliptic curve signatures,
which I'll talk about next,
that are sort of displacing RSA,
in many cases.
So it hasn't really taken
off for web certificates
but a lot of other types of
encryption, signing, things
like that.
Cryptocurrencies are also one of
the big uses of elliptic curve
signatures because
they're somewhat more
powerful and somewhat
smaller and really cool.
And we will talk about
those in three minutes.
So intermission, three minutes.
Stretch.
Ask random questions.
Talk to the neighbors.
OK.
So they're using
these elliptic curves,
which are curves of
the form y squared
plus x cubed plus some
coefficient x squared
plus some constant.
And in the case of
Bitcoin, it's very simple.
It's y squared equals
x cubed plus 7.
And that's the
curve Bitcoin uses.
And this is what it looks
like if you plot it.
And that seems really simple.
We can totally understand that.
But it gets a little weird.
With elliptic curves, you have
these points on the curves,
right?
And another property is if
you draw a straight line that
intersects this curve--
you could also draw
a line which doesn't
intersect at all, fine--
but if you draw a line
that intersects the curve,
it will intersect
in three places.
So if I draw a line here, it
intersects these three dots.
If I draw a line here,
it intersects here, here,
and then it'll intersect
somewhere down here.
It'll intersect in three
places unless I take a tangent.
If I draw, and I try
to be like, oh, I'm
going only intersect
in two, well, I
can take a tangent
here, and it'll
intersect in one more place.
What we can do, though,
is we can say, well,
if you intersect at a
tangent, that's kind
of like intersecting twice.
We can deal with that.
AUDIENCE: What if you
draw a vertical line?
TADGE DRYJA: If you draw a
vertical-- oh, yeah, vertical
line, then there's
a point at infinity,
which shouldn't happen.
AUDIENCE: But
infinity is included--
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --in the set
of points on the curve?
So it's like there's
three points, anyway.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
There's a point up there--
sort of.
In the practice of
signing and stuff,
you probably shouldn't hit it.
Yeah.
But so what we do is we say,
OK, well, three points in a line
equals zero.
And so if we take this
point plus this point
plus this point, that's zero.
Another way to say that is
P plus Q minus R equals 0,
or P plus Q equals negative
R. And another property is
the negation of a point
is just that same point
with the y-coordinate flipped.
So if this is
negative R, we just
go down to the
bottom side of this,
and this is positive
R. Similarly, minus P
would be here.
Minus Q would be here.
And if you had a point Z here,
negative Z would be up here.
This is how it's constructed.
However, we don't actually
use these nice curves.
We chop them up in
modulo something.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You have P plus Q
equals negative R. Should it
be positive R?
TADGE DRYJA: No.
In this case, R is up here.
Right.
In this case--
P. Wait, hold on.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TADGE DRYJA: Oh, shoot.
Sorry.
P plus Q equals R. Right.
OK.
Never mind.
Yeah.
The picture is correct.
But so basically,
P plus Q equals R
because R is down here.
Sorry.
Yeah, that's why.
OK.
This is R. This is
negative R. So yeah,
P plus Q equals R,
not negative R. Sorry.
When you want to multiply
a point, you can.
Because you can take
a tangent, right?
So you can add
these points, right?
You can say, OK, I want
the sum of P and Q,
which will be down here--
R. I want 2P, for example.
Well, with 2P, I
can take a tangent
and then find
where it intersects
and then go down
below the curve.
So for example, if this
is G, I say OK, well, G
starts here, take the tangent,
find where it intersects
and then drop down.
And this is 2G.
So it's a simple
way to say, well,
I'm not really multiplying.
I'm just adding it
to itself, which is
sort of what multiplication is.
And I can do this
again and again.
So I say, oh, I want 4G.
I take the tangent at 2G,
find the intersection here,
drop down.
OK.
Here's 4G.
Take the tangent
here, it'll go--
I can keep doing that
and get 2G, 4G, 8G.
And if I want intermediate
things, like, well, I want 3G,
well, I draw a line between G
and 2G, find the intersection,
and find the sum.
So yeah?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: When you find
the intersection of that
[INAUDIBLE] the intersection
of the modulo of something,
does it just--
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, yeah.
So the pictures look
nice, in this case, right?
It's like, hey,
there's this curve.
And it looks so simple.
And we can graphically
do it on graph paper.
But when you're actually
doing it on the computer,
it looks more like this.
Everything is modulo
some giant prime number.
You could still draw lines.
It's just that the curve is now
all these crazy-looking dots.
And you still have that
symmetry from the y-axis.
But the way the computer does
it is all modulo a number.
So it doesn't actually
map to a nice curve.
So the fun thing about
when you're doing modulo
is all the properties
stay the same, right?
With regular numbers,
you can still
do addition,
multiplication, division
all modulo some number, and
it still all works, right?
So same with this.
You still have the same
draw a line between P and Q,
and you get to here.
And then you flip over the
y-axis, and now this is R.
Similarly, you can
take a tangent--
although a tangent is harder
to visually see because there's
no obvious curve here--
but the equations work the same.
OK.
So you don't need to know
exactly why these things work
or curves.
But we're going to go through
what you can do with these
and what properties you have.
OK.
So we've defined these
points on a curve
and how this curve works.
And then we also have
regular old numbers, right?
So what we'll do from now
on is say, like a and b,
our lowercase numbers,
these are scalars.
Scalars just means
regular old numbers.
The uppercase A and B will refer
to points on the curve, OK?
So from now on, lowercase
is regular number,
uppercase is point
on this curve,
or point on this mashed-up thing
that we still call a curve.
OK.
So I'll go through what
operations we can do,
and then we can see
what use those have.
So first, scalars.
You can add, subtract,
multiply, divide.
You can do whatever
you want, right?
These are just regular
numbers, like five or 17 or 22.
Everything's OK, right?
Easy.
Everything here is integers.
We're doing modulo
some big prime number,
so there's no decimal points.
I think in this class,
we'll probably never
have to use floating
point, which is great,
because floating point
always scares me.
It's also uint.
These are like
unsigned integers.
You can do it with signed.
But since you're
modulo some big number,
it's like unsigned
numbers that loop around.
So it's really
nice for computers.
Computers deal very
well with these things.
Computers are good at
floating point, as well.
But the thing is,
in cryptography,
a lot of times floating point
ends up with error, right,
where you're pretty
close, but you've
got some fixed amount of
decimal places you can store.
Your floating point goes
out to some precision.
And then error can accumulate.
And in a lot of cryptography,
you want zero error, right?
Like in a hash function,
it's pretty exact.
So a lot of times,
the cryptography,
you use integers instead of
floating point or rational
numbers.
OK.
So with scalars, these
are just regular integers,
natural numbers even.
You can do these.
All the operations,
you're familiar with.
That's fairly straightforward.
With points.
So you can add and
subtract the points, right?
We showed how you
do that visually.
And then the equations
for it, the computer
can do that pretty quick.
However, this is not defined.
Multiplication and division
with two points is undefined.
It's just not clear
how you do it.
It's not something in
this system, right?
It's a group.
You've got one operation.
You don't have this other one.
So you can add and
subtract points,
but you can't multiply them.
Any questions about this?
This is pretty important.
Make sense?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In the previous case,
when you were adding points,
what is defined as addition?
Are you adding only
the y components?
TADGE DRYJA: You use both
the x and y-coordinates
to add, right?
So when you're doing
it in the computer,
you're saying,
OK, well, what are
the x- and y-coordinates of P?
What are the x- and
y-coordinates of Q?
Find the slope here and
where it intersects the axis.
And then see where it'll
intersect the curve
at another point.
AUDIENCE: Addition Is literally
defined as compute that point.
It is not a function of adding
the x- and y-coordinates.
AUDIENCE: Gotcha.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
Well, I mean-- yeah.
But the equation would be--
since the computer doesn't
actually look at the curve,
you just say, OK.
Find the Px- and y-coordinate.
Find the Qx- and y-coordinate.
Find the slope, and then
find where it intersects,
and then compute for that for R.
OK.
So yeah.
You can add and subtract.
You cannot multiply and
divide these points.
Sounds good?
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How
would you subtract?
TADGE DRYJA: Ah.
You just go down, right?
So if I want P minus Q, I
should say P plus negative Q.
And negative Q is just right
here, right down on the axis.
So I say, OK, I want
P minus Q. I go here.
Find it.
It's going to be
up there somewhere.
So yeah.
You just add the
negative of the number.
I guess that's another thing.
Minus B-- negative B-- is
also an operation I can do.
I can negate something,
which lets me do subtraction.
AUDIENCE: For those of
you with math backgrounds,
this is defining
a group operation
on the field of natural
numbers, modulo--
TADGE DRYJA: Which is a big one.
AUDIENCE: --and using
this elliptic curve.
So this is A. And the
only thing that's defined
is addition and subtraction
and not multiplication.
TADGE DRYJA: Right.
You can do the same
group operations
without using elliptic curves.
And so you can just
do exponential modulo
big prime number.
I'm going to use
curves because it's
what is used in all
the actual systems.
But you can sort of forget about
the curve after this, right?
You can say, well, look, we just
have these uppercase variables
and these lowercase variables.
And the fact that it's on a
curve, we can sort of abstract
away and just know that we
have these different types,
essentially.
And when you're in the
computer, you're just like,
yeah, that's a point.
That's a scalar.
Here are the
operations I can do,
and I just run the functions.
OK.
So the next part, when you
mix scalars and points,
so mixed operations.
You cannot add a point and an
integer or subtract a point
and an integer.
That's not defined, right?
You say, OK, here's
this point p minus 7.
Well, does that mean
move the x-axis?
Does that mean move the y?
It's not defined.
However, you can do this, right?
You can multiply and divide.
So you can say, well,
A times 2, well,
you take the tangent, right?
It's just A plus A. Or A times
7, is we just break it down as
A plus A plus A plus A 17 times.
We can also divide,
which is a little weird
because we have to
find the inverse of B
and then multiply by that--
the multiplicative inverse
of B modulo the order.
But anyway, you can do these.
This is a little
trickier because you
have to compute what, like,
B to the negative 1 is
and multiply by that.
You can do it.
So you can do these things where
you have points times scalars.
But you cannot add.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So 2A is
basically joining
the tangent to A,
[INAUDIBLE] beginning.
TADGE DRYJA: Yep.
So that was here.
If this is G, this is 2G.
Find the tangent, find the
intersection, and then negate.
OK.
So you can do that.
That's cool.
You cannot do that.
OK.
So roster of
operations we can do.
This is it.
And this is sort of,
if you think of that,
you can do all
these cool things.
It's sort of amazing,
all the crazy things
you can do with just
these operations, right?
With regular numbers, you
can do whatever you want.
That's obvious.
And with these points, you
can add and subtract them.
And when you mix, you
can multiply and divide.
And that's it.
OK.
Any questions so far?
You don't have to worry too
much about the curves and all
of the math and stuff.
But you just sort of say,
OK, here's my toolbox.
Here's what I can do.
OK.
Any questions?
Good?
So now what we can do is we
can define a one-way function
sort of like a hash function,
sort of like multiplying
p times q to get n.
What we will need,
in addition to this,
is everyone pick some point on
the curve, and we call it G.
And it's random.
And we want it to be
somewhat verifiably random.
We just all have to
agree on a point.
And we'll call this
the generator point.
Another property is that, since
it's all modulo, this number,
if B is too big, you'll
wrap around, right,
because it's all modulo, this n.
So it's called a
generator point because--
and every point on
the curve can be one--
if you keep, say,
2G, 3G, 4G, 5G,
eventually, you'll
get back to G, right?
It's all finite.
OK so does anyone
have an idea, OK,
how would we make some
cool one-way function
given these operations
and the fact
that we have an
agreed-upon point?
It's not super obvious,
but it's actually
fairly straightforward.
Once you see it,
you're like, oh.
Any ideas?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you
take your point G,
and you multiply
it by some scalar,
and you publish where the
point is [INAUDIBLE] scalars.
TADGE DRYJA: Yep, yep.
OK.
So your private key--
let's say private
key, lowercase a,
it's just some 256 bit
random number, scalar,
exactly the same as 32 bytes
like in a lamport signature.
And your public key
is just a times G.
And your public key is
now a point on a curve.
We're going to call
it uppercase A.
And you have a 32 byte
x-coordinate, right--
because the x
dimension is 256 bits--
32 byte y-coordinate.
So it's 64 bytes--
pretty small.
Anyone have another
quick optimization
on how you could reduce this?
So there's a lot of
optimization going on
in all these different
cryptocurrency systems.
Because they don't
scale too well.
But any idea of how
to get that down?
AUDIENCE: Can you hash it?
TADGE DRYJA: You could.
So you could hash it.
You'd make it into 32 bytes.
There's a more useful way.
But if you hash it, you still
have to reveal it later, right?
So it helps, making
a pubkey hash.
And that's what
Bitcoin did initially
is you'd have the
64 byte public keys.
And then you'd send
to the hash of them.
There's a nicer way.
Any ideas?
OK.
So the thing is it's
symmetric, right?
So the curve is symmetric
about the x-axis.
Any ideas?
yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you just code
one of the x- or y-coordinates
and say which side?
TADGE DRYJA: Right.
So you take the x-coordinate
and encode that.
And then just that one bit--
4-- it's on the top.
It's on the bottom.
And then let them figure out
exactly where it is, right?
So you can encode the
x-coordinate only and 1 bit
for y, and then you're
down to 33 bytes.
It's a little annoying
because the 33 bytes, well,
one of those bytes
is going to be empty.
It's just going to have one
bit in it for up or down.
But whatever.
So you can do that, and
that's also really cool.
OK.
Any questions so far?
AUDIENCE: Could you encode
a [INAUDIBLE] and same
up and down?
Could you just encode
an [INAUDIBLE]??
TADGE DRYJA: Huh.
Probably.
But I don't think
it would be smaller.
I think you'd have to
probably have the same size
if you use some other
coordinate system.
Hm.
Yeah, you could encode a slope--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the [INAUDIBLE].
TADGE DRYJA: And you
say it intersects,
and it's at the slope, and
which side of the axis?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and if it
crosses multiple times,
which one of the--
TADGE DRYJA: You probably could.
I think you would
end up the same size.
But yeah.
But it might be faster
for some things.
There's all sorts of
different encodings.
AUDIENCE: I guarantee that you
have an integer in the end.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
So you might not
be on the curve.
But there's a
similar problem here
where it might not
be on the curve.
You can encode a point
that's also off the curve.
And so when you actually
get a public key,
like over the wire
in these systems,
the first thing
you usually do is
make sure this is
a valid public key,
and it's actually on the curve.
Because there's a lot
of points that aren't.
And sometimes you can screw
around with the code that way.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you define the
scalar multiplication again?
how does it go?
TADGE DRYJA: OK.
So scalar multiplication--
a times G is, basically,
break it out as G plus G
plus G plus G plus G a times.
And G plus G is find
the tangent of G
and then find the
intersection, right?
So this is G. This is 2G,
right-- tangent, intersect,
and then the negation.
And so you just do
that a bazillion times.
However, since you can
find 2G and then you
can double 2G to get 4G
and double 4G to get 8G,
you can come up with
powers of 2 of G
and then add those
powers of 2 to do
a much more efficient addition
so that you can practically
make--
because little a is going to
be some huge decimal 50-digit
number or whatever.
So you're going to have
to do this two, four, six,
eight binary expansion
and then add them all up.
OK.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You're chucking
everything into some grain size
to get these.
You're [INAUDIBLE]
a continuous curve.
TADGE DRYJA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It feels like if you
have 306 bits in the original,
you shouldn't be able to get all
the way down to 32 bits, right?
Because you just want
to make sure that you--
TADGE DRYJA: This?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
If you removed a
byte of precision,
would you actually
be losing any power?
TADGE DRYJA: What you can do
a little-- what you can do
is you can just
say, look, I'm only
going to allow public keys
that are on the top, positive y
component.
And everything
else is disallowed.
You could have that as
a rule of your system,
and then you can get
rid of the y bit.
But the thing is
the y-coordinate
does affect some of the
things like signatures, things
that you'll later use.
So you can just say, OK, look,
implicitly y bit is positive.
And you lose 1 bit of security.
Because there is a
difference between
the positive and negative
thing if you're doing signing.
But yeah.
And so some systems do do that.
And it makes things easier.
There's some signing
systems that do that.
OK.
I'm going to go
to the next part.
ECDSA is used in bitcoin.
I'm actually not
going to explain it.
It's a worse signature system.
So the reason why this was
used was the better system
was patented.
And so there's a clearer, more
obvious, cleaner, more powerful
signature system that was
patented by this German guy,
Claus Schnorr.
And so no one used it, or
maybe a few people used it.
But in general, with open
source things and web standards,
patents are really
hard to work with.
And so all the
cryptographers said,
well, we'll make
this other system
that's different enough that it
doesn't infringe on the patent.
And it's kind of ugly.
It does work as a
signature scheme.
But actually, I'm
going to explain
the Schnorr signatures,
which make a lot more sense,
are easier to understand
and manipulate,
and the patent has expired,
so we can all use it.
And it will probably
be going into Bitcoin.
And some cryptocurrencies
use Schnorr signatures.
I think Monero uses a
Schnorr-like signature.
But Bitcoin will
probably be putting it
into Bitcoin in the
next year or so.
So all these things will
be much more applicable,
and you can use them.
And there's code out.
You can use them now.
OK.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Patent has expired--
free to use the better
algo that must not be named.
So yeah.
People don't call it
Schnorr signature as much.
Because it's like, well, this
is the guy who prevented us
from using this for 20 years.
And there's modifications to it.
OK.
So the elliptic curve signature,
for lack of a better name.
This is something
of a simplification.
And there's reading
about how you can really
do it the right way.
But this does give
you the right idea.
And for a single signer,
this is secure, and it works.
But later things, you might want
to actually add other stuff.
So the idea is you've got
your message m, right?
Same as in lamport,
same as in RSA, you've
got a message m and a
private key lowercase a.
And your public key is
a times G, like we said.
And then, when you want
to sign, you actually
make a one-time use key
pair for the signature only.
And they usually call that k.
And k is a new random number.
It's the private key.
And you're going to
multiply it by G.
And they call this R.
I don't know why they
use these letters, but anyway.
K times G is R. R is the other
public key you're using just
for this signature.
And then the signature itself
is quite straightforward.
As the signer, you
compute s, which is k--
this new private key
you just made up--
minus the hash of your
message concatenated with R,
this public key-- so you encode
the public key in 33 bytes,
stick it in there--
multiplied by a, your
normal private key.
And then your
signature is the pair--
the R point and the s scalar.
This is a little bit
of a bunch to process.
But it's actually
not too bad, right?
This is a scalar--
32 bytes-- that you made up.
The hash, this is a message,
also going to be however long.
This is 33 bytes.
You concatenate them
together-- hash.
You end up with
another 32 byte scalar.
You multiply those two scalars.
So actually, the only
elliptic curve operation
here is calculating what R is.
When you're actually
calculating s,
this is all just scalar,
so it's very fast.
So in terms of practical
computer stuff,
doing these operations is a
little bit on the slow side.
Because you're doing those
point additions quite a number
of times.
So a decent code,
a decent CPU, can
do on the order of thousands
of these types of operations
per second, which is decent.
You can do a decent amount,
but it is kind of slow.
And it's considerably
slower than hash functions.
You can do a million iterations
of a hash function per second
on a core, or you can
do, maybe, 1,000 or 2,000
of this kind of thing, so
still pretty fast but slower.
And so this signing procedure,
this takes a bit of time.
This takes, actually,
very little time.
Because you're just subtracting
and multiplying 32 byte scalar
integers, which is much faster.
OK.
So does this make sense?
We'll go a little bit of
how you can't forge this.
OK.
Sorry.
So first verification.
So how would you, if
anyone knows or can think,
how would you
verify this, right?
I know their public key--
capital A, which is
little a times G--
and then they're
giving me a message m,
and they're giving me a
signature, which is R and s.
And they've computed
it this way.
I can't verify this
equation myself
because I don't know what k is.
I don't know what
little a is, right?
I'm just given R, s, m, and big
A. So how would I verify this?
AUDIENCE: Can I, for example,
take the hash of the message,
use R, and then try
random a's and that--
on, sorry.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
Do you have one?
AUDIENCE: So trying random is
probably [INAUDIBLE] because--
TADGE DRYJA:
There's a lot, yeah.
AUDIENCE: --there's too many.
The old one that
you don't know it.
But I think one more thing
you could do is take little s
and multiply it by big G.
TADGE DRYJA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And then do some--
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
So the basic idea--
yeah, you're right.
Multiply this side
by G. Then you also
have to multiply the
other side by G, right?
So you say, OK, well,
as the verifier--
I've got R, I've got s--
I multiply s by
G, and now I have
to multiply this side by G.
And what'll that look like?
Well, what's k times G?
AUDIENCE: R.
TADGE DRYJA: R. What's
little a times G?
Big A. So yeah.
I want to verify.
I want to verify that
this equation was used,
right-- s equals k minus
this hash times little a.
Multiply both sides
by G, I get s times G
equals k times G minus the
hash thing times little a times
G. This is big A. This is R.
Hey, now I know everything
here as the verifier, right?
I know what s time G is.
I know what R is.
I know what big A is.
I know what's going
into this hash function.
And so I just say, OK.
Well, I rearrange it a little,
and I say, is R equal to this?
And if it is, that's
a good signature.
If it's not, it's
not a good signature.
Any questions about this?
Does this makes sense, mostly?
So for the verification, it's
a bit more CPU-intense, right?
You're given a scalar.
You multiply by G. You
also have to multiply A--
this is actually more costly--
you have to multiply
A by this hash.
The reason that's
more costly-- it's
still a scalar times a point.
The thing is, since G is
used for multiplying a lot,
you precompute all sorts
of coefficients times G,
and you store them in RAM
or in your CPU somewhere.
So multiplying by G
is a little bit faster
because you do it a lot,
you can precompute a lot,
whereas multiplying by A is
different each time for all
the different signatures.
So this is a little
bit slower, in general.
So it takes a little
bit more CPU time
to verify a signature
than to create one,
something like twice as much.
But still, you can
do this pretty fast.
On a modern computer, you can
do thousands of these a second.
OK.
Any questions so far?
I'll go a little bit into why
this is not forgible, right?
So I want to forge a signature.
Well, I don't know little a.
But why don't I make up
a k and compute s and R?
But I need a, right?
So I'm going to say, OK,
this is the equation I want.
I'll just make up my own
k and make up my own k, s,
that'll satisfy this.
Without a, I really can't
make a valid s, right?
I can make something up here.
But I can't compute it because
I don't know here, right?
I can try to grind through hash
functions, but it won't work.
The basic problem
is if I make up an s
and solve for R, right--
I can say, well,
I know what R is--
but the thing is R is in
the hash function, as well.
It's the one-wayness of
the hash function that
actually breaks this, right?
So I could say, well,
let me solve for R. Well,
R is the hash of m and R
times a plus s times G.
If I can come up with a
valid R here, I can do this.
The problem is R is defined
by the hash of R in this case.
I can't compute this, and I
can't cancel this out, right?
So you can see just like, OK,
I need to solve for R. Well,
but it's already in here.
I'm stuck.
If I don't know k, I can't come
up with a signature, either.
OK.
There is one footgun
with EC signatures.
If you use the same R value
for different signatures
with the same pubkey, you
reveal your private key.
So k has to be random
and new every time.
If you look through
the equation,
you'll see how you can solve--
if you have two of the same
k's with different s's--
you can solve for k.
And then, once you
solve for k given
this, if you know
what k is, you can
find what little a is,
right, as a verifier.
You can say, well,
you gave me s.
That's part of the signature.
I know this whole coefficient.
If I know k, I can solve for
little a by dividing this out.
So always use a new k value.
There have been many
cases where people don't.
Probably the most famous one
is PlayStation 3 used ECDSA.
And they used a fixed k value
for signing all their code.
And that allowed people to
calculate their private keys
and then run pirated games.
That was actually
the first time I
learned about elliptic
curve signatures,
in 2010 or something.
So actually, there's
interesting tutorials
written by the hackers who
broke Playstation 3 about how
this works.
And that's when I
first read about it.
OK.
We're almost out of time.
Any questions about
this stuff so far?
OK.
So this is a
signature algorithm.
It's like, OK, fine.
This works.
I can sign, same as lamport
signatures, same as RSA.
What's really nice about
the elliptic curve stuff
is you can do more
than just signatures.
There's all sorts of
fun things you can do.
And it seems like a
fairly unexplored area
in that I've found
fun things that you
can do that I guess are novel.
And I'm not an expert
on this at all.
It's just that it's a
fairly new area of research
in how to do cool
bitcoiny cryptocurrency
things with these curves
and points and stuff.
So I'll go through a couple
fun things you can do.
Fun with points.
OK.
So I'm not using an asterisk.
Just b times G.
So let's say Alice
has a public key A. Bob
has a public key B, right,
which is little a times G
or little b times G. Well,
this is weird.
Little a times big B--
Alice's private key multiplied
by Bob's public key--
you can do that, right?--
is equal to Bob's private
key times Alice's public
key, right?
It's commutative.
The multiplication
is commutative.
That's weird, right?
It's just a times G times
b, which is the same--
or it doesn't matter
the order-- it's
the same as b times G times a,
which is the same as a times
b times G. And let's
call that C. C-- this
is called a Diffie-Hellman
key exchange point.
Diffie and Hellman are two also
late-'70s PhD students who came
up with all this cool stuff.
No, wait.
Diffie was a PhD student.
Hellman was his advisor?
I don't remember.
Anyway, they came
up with this idea.
And this is a shared point.
What would this be useful for?
It's actually super useful.
Can you think of like, oh, OK.
We can do this.
We can compute C. Why
would we want to do that?
Any applications
you can think of?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Trying to share
keys with people without both
of them knowing who
they are and evaluating
the other set of keys.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
It's really cool to share keys.
So this is also done if
you have a web browser.
I think it's all elliptic curve
Diffie-Hellman now, mostly.
But if you have a web browser
and you go to a website,
this is happening, basically,
for every HTTPS request.
Because you can
use C as a sort of
shared key and encrypt
things with it.
The idea is big A can be public.
Big B can be public.
Point C will not be public.
The only way to
compute it is to know
either Alice's private
key-- little a--
or Bob's private key, little b.
Even though you can
see the public keys,
you can't compute C from
just the public keys, right?
Because big A times big
B, that's not defined.
You can't multiply the points.
You have to multiply
the point by a scalar.
And since you don't
know the scalars
from viewing this
exchange, you can't
compute C. But Alice and
Bob can both compute C.
So this is really useful.
You can compute C. You
can use it for encryption.
You can use it to prove you
are who you say you are.
You can use it as an
interactive verification
where you say, OK, I'm Bob.
I'm going to make random point.
I'm going to give that to you.
Prove you know your
private key-- little a--
by telling me what C is, right?
So I can make a random
key here, give it to you.
You return C. I verify that
that's the right C. And I say,
OK, well you must know little a.
You haven't shown me
a little a, but you've
proven that you know it,
so proof of knowledge
of the private key.
So you can use that for
logins instead of passwords.
And it's much simpler
than a signature.
So that's really cool.
All sorts of things
you can do with that.
The last part, you can
have fun with points.
And I use this in my software.
So you say, OK, well,
there's a public key A.
There's a public
key B. And we'll
define D as the sum of
these two public keys.
The thing is if you're
summing these two public keys,
it's commutative,
and it is the same
as saying the sum of the two
private keys times G, right?
a times G plus b times
G is the same as a plus
b times G, which is another
really cool property.
So what if I compute
this public key D,
and I say I want a
signature from public key D?
You can.
And you so the
private key, little d,
which can sign for this, is
just little a plus little b.
So you can make a combined key.
And then either party--
Alice has little a,
Bob has a little b--
and they could reveal
it to each other
and allow the other person to
make a signature with D later.
I use this in the lightning
network software I've had,
where, basically, you say,
look, we'll compute D,
and I can give you the
private key, right?
I'm Bob.
And I say, OK, here's point b.
Here's point a.
We add them together.
And then, Alice, if I give
you my private key, now
you can sign, but
I can't, right?
So I'll give you
the private key to D
from some information I have.
Or you could give me
the private key to D
by sharing little a with me.
So this is another
useful thing where
you can have something
where both parties know
that neither party can
sign unless they give them
something.
And you can use that for bitcoin
addresses, things like that.
Before you even
get to signatures,
you can share keys and stuff.
There's all sorts
of super fun things
you can do with these points
and curves and systems.
Multisignatures-- I put
a link to a PDF file
that's very recent and kind
of overkill and over my head,
as well.
But you can do signatures where
you aggregate the signatures.
But
There's ways to
say, OK, well, I'm
going to add all these
R points, and I'm
going to add all these s points.
And I can have
signatures that are
from a bunch of
different people that
collapse into the same
size as a single signature.
And I can verify that they're
all signing the same thing
or, possibly, that they're
all signing different things.
So I have 10
different signatures
from different people
signing different messages.
But I can add up
all the s values.
I have to keep the R values.
But now these 10 signatures,
instead of being 64 bytes
each are more like
32 bites each.
And there's one extra 32
byte value for all of them.
So there's a lot
of really cool ways
you can combine things,
make things smaller,
make things really versatile,
where we can share keys,
things like that,
which you can't
do with hash-based
signatures, hash functions.
And so it's really fun.
One worry is that if
quantum computers ever
become really a thing, all
this stuff stops working.
All the elliptic curve
stuff doesn't work anymore.
You can figure out what
people's private keys are,
whereas hash stuff, hash
things like lamport signatures,
still work.
So there's some talk
of hey, we should
prepare for if that ever happens
and make efficient, effective
hash-based signatures
and use them
in something like
Bitcoin or Ethereum.
People haven't yet because
the overhead is really high.
It's really big.
The real thing is
all these fun things
might disappear in
the next 10, 20 years.
Who knows?
But there's lots of cool stuff.
What do we do with this?
So we're not going
to do anything yet
in terms of problem sets.
It's a little hard to
program it directly.
But there's libraries.
And the libraries
have fairly easy use,
where it's multiply
by G is a function,
and multiply by this
point is a function.
So this is groundwork for
cool stuff you can do.
And it's really nice
because it's a new area.
And I'm not an expert on this,
but I've come up with stuff
that people have cited me on.
And they're like, yeah, I guess
no one thought of that before.
There's a lot of things.
There's one very
recent one called
Taproot, where it's one line.
You're like, oh, yeah.
That works.
And it's just these sort of
elliptic curve operations.
It's like, yeah, that works.
That's really useful.
How did no one think of that?
It's one line.
Wow.
So there's just
not a ton of people
working on this kind of stuff.
And so it's kind of fun.